voilà j'ai le plaisir de recevoir
maintenant mary higgins clark est un
très grand nom de la littérature
policière on la surnomme la reine du
suspense
son dernier livre paru chez albin michel
souviens toi grand prix de la
littérature policière en france pour la
nuit du renard en 1980 qui était votre
premier grand succès et depuis chaque
année vous sortez un livre quasiment
tout le temps au printemps ces services
est un aveu c'est le bon âge c'est le
bon moment
alors il ya toujours dans votre dans
votre écriture un très grand sens du
détail alors à la fois je sais que vous
travaillez beaucoup sur de la
documentation vous vous lisez beaucoup
des faits divers des journaux les
minutes des procès les archives et en
même temps vous enquêtez beaucoup sur
les vêtements les lieux ça participe
pour vous de la conception de l'écriture
ce souci du détail
oui c'est très important parce que
lorsque j'assiste à un procès si
j'arrive à trouver le petit quelque
chose dont je me dis ça va me servir
dans mon intrigue et bien à ce moment-là
j'entreprends ma propre recherche parce
que je vais trouver quelque chose donc
je ne savais même pas que celui
recherché
vous savez vous lisez quelque chose et
vous dites ça c'est très bon je m'en
servir dans un autre livre alors que si
je demande à quelqu'un de me trouver des
réponses
eh ben je vais perdre tesla rock à ce
moment-là j'appelle la police et jeudi
si accor et rejetés sur le rivage si on
pense que c'est un accident
est ce qu'il peut arriver sur telle
plage ou sur telle plage et on me répond
et je dis bon alors imaginons que des
gens ne pense pas que ce soit un
accident
ils vont s'arrêter vont dire pourquoi
pensez-vous que c'est un accident les
policiers m'ont pris très au sérieux par
exemple jeune j'ai posé ces questions
mais je pose beaucoup de questions
j'appelle la morgue
j'appelle le bureau des personnes
disparues si j'avais fait des allusions
médical je demande toujours un médecin
de lire les pages qui concerne les
aspects médicaux de mon lit pour
m'assurer que je n'ai pas d'une bêtise
mais il ya toujours quelqu'un qui trouve
un petit détail une petite erreur
quelque part et j'attends toujours que
l'on me fasse remarquer cela vous
ressemblez absolument à vos livres c'est
à dire vous dites avec un charmant
sourire des horreurs monstrueux à ce que
vous livre c'est absolument c'est à dire
que on est on est dans un univers un
petit peu quotidien on a souvent comparé
vos livres à l'univers de hitchcock à la
fois dans votre maîtrise de l'art du
suspense
et puis aussi dans cette faculté que
vous avez à saisir les moments de
basculement vers le moment où des gens
ordinaires et pacifique deviennent des
meurtrier sanguinaire des moments où une
vie ordinaire bascule dans le dans
l'horreur c'est le cas dans ce livre qui
s'appelle souviens toi c'est ce
moment-là de bascule qui vous intéresse
le plus qui vous excite le plus dans
l'écriture ah ouais tout ce qui
m'intéresse c'est le moment où
l'ordinaire lorsque vous regardez les
enfants qui jouaient le sort ne sont
plus là ou bien lorsque vous avez raison
toutes les portes se fait là et il fait
nuit
c'est tout ce qui se déclenche dans les
toilettes c'est effrayant effrayant
alors que quelque chose se passe jamais
vraiment utiliser la violence de ses
films on entendait des bruits de pas qui
suivait un personnage ou bien entendu
une porte qui grâce à calonne-liévin les
yeux quelqu'un qui reflétait leur serait
beaucoup plus peur et la violence filmée
parce que c'est votre esprit qui se met
à tourner à ce moment là c'est un petit
peu ce que vous faites aussi parce qu'il
ya assez peu de descriptions je sais pas
de meurtres violences
en revanche vous essayer de chercher des
actes des attitudes plus terrifiant
encore que l'acte lui même
vous êtes avec votre meilleure amie une
jeune femme par exemple avec son
meilleur ami elle le regarde je vous
vois vous avez une soirée admirable et
puis tout d'un coup vos yeux changer
votre regard se transforme et tout d'un
coup je me rends compte que je suis avec
le meurtrier
c'est qu'ils avaient toute confiance ne
voudrait se promener avec un assassin
veille où personne ne voudrait se fait à
côté d'un homme très agréable qui sourit
qui rit et puis vous avez l'impression
que c'est là que votre amie est morte
que c'est dans ces circonstances là ça
vous fait peur ou bien vous êtes dans
une maison ces derniers livres par
exemple la femme avait perdu un petit
garçon en traversant une voie de chemin
de fer et puis elle est toute seule dans
la maison la nuit elle se réveille elle
entend le bruit du train qui rentre chez
elle dans sa maison
ça ça fait peur et c'est cela qui me
plaisent et c'est là que j'aime faire
les choses implicite là les choses qu'on
ne voit pas qui sont là au point et je
crois que cela marche assez bien et
j'écris des livres sur des gens très
gentils très agréable dont la vie est
envahi par les ennuis
ils sont avec leurs enfants avec leur
famille avec leur soeur et je crois que
les gens peuvent s'identifier à eux dans
ces conditions les lecteurs j'évoquais
hitchcock on pourrait aussi évoquer le
rosebud de citizen kane d'orson welles
parce que tous vos personnages ont tous
le secret de beaucoup de vos personnages
et dans souviens toi aussi
c'est toujours un moment donné l'enfance
soit le rapport aux enfants la l'héroïne
qui a perdu son son petit garçon
ou alors un événement qui s'est passé
dans l'enfance et qui expliquent un
moment donné par exemple le comportement
meurtrier
c'est quelque chose à quoi vous croyez
presque psychologiquement ça cette
détermination très forte de l'enfant sur
sur vos personnages
tout ce qui vous arrive dans votre
enfance va marquer votre vie derrière va
affecter votre ville intérieure
si vous conduisez une voiture et que
votre enfant mort alors c'est vous qui
était au volant vous vous lavez vous
sentez coupable si vous êtes kidnappée à
l'âge de 4 ans qui survient dans l'âme
et lille et puis si l'on en croit vos
parents à 6 ans si vous avez eu une
expérience épouvantable il est certain
qu'à 21 ans vous aurez des problèmes
tout va exploser et vous êtes une
personne différente
votre personnalité est différente de ce
fait si votre père est en voyage
et si vous ne comprenez pas pourquoi
s'il est souvent voyage vous vous
demandez pourquoi vous l'avez toujours
accepté puis un jour dans un hôpital
vous trouvez face à face au cadavre
d'une jeune fille qui a le même visage
que venir alors vous vous demandez
pourquoi c'est toujours le pourquoi
avant d'écrire un livre il faut se
demander pourquoi cela s'est passé
et puis il faut tirer une flèche sur une
cible et chacun dans le livre doit se
rapprocher de cette cible il faut que
tout le monde arrive à la cible en même
temps il faut qu'il y ait une raison
pour cela une raison valable
elle est hypnotisant elle s'appelle mary
higgins clark son dernier livre souviens
toi chez albin michel et ça doit pas de
prise de passer d'histoire et avec elle
une façon de mettre tout ça à bon bref
le livre est absolument formidable
[Musique]